Rex Tillerson was just out stood he was
outed and and everybody seems to be
fired it is half but we're not firing
the person who ought to be fired it is
half of the top level positions in
Trump's administration there's been
turnover half in the last little over a
year since he's been in office this is
not normal no that's not it really is
not normal I love a historic perspective
I have been around and in administration
I started in a Ford administration you
know I tell my students that I was in
the Ford administration they have no
idea I say it's right after the Lincoln
administration yeah
but no this is very unusual Conant I
haven't seen anything like this in terms
of turnover and I worry that we may have
a guy just doesn't want to work with
people right so CEO past well it is
interesting diagnosis is that here maybe
that no I listened please you said it
and now you'll be audited
you know what I find interesting is that
it almost his genius seems to be and I
you know I've been around for a while
not as long as you but a while and I
have you a lot longer than I but anyway
I'm getting I I've never seen a
president who has generated this much
day-to-day coverage of himself that does
seem to be his amazing talent and I it
almost feels to me like he cares about
that more than he does about getting
things done sometimes I think that how
did you that that's an insight that I
hadn't I'm capable of things that's the
most kind of something that's the most
condescending thing he is a brilliant
marketer yeah of himself
yeah and that's where he got you know
that's how he started that's he was he
the birther movement and The Apprentice
and everything else he markets himself
he makes himself the center of the news
every day and he pushes everything else
out and that is that's okay for somebody
who's on the fringes of politics and on
the fringes of entertainment but to be
the President of the United States it
becomes a little bit dangerous
you